decapitations tranquilizer darts and
sorts of sharing of beer Deadpool and
Wolverine's feelings about each other
are hard to describe time to make the
chimichangas Wolverine and Deadpool had
the first team up years before Wade
Wilson even began his career as a
costumed mercenary in Deadpool nerdy 30
a teenage Wade accidentally gets
handcuffed to Wolverine when Logan
crashes as High School prom while
fighting hydra agents although Logan
initially protects Wade from getting
shot the Merkin waiting proves he's
already got some skills when he uses an
electric guitar and symbol to take out
some Hydra goons and shield Wolverine
from their bullets impressed Wolverine
advisor's way to take that special
talent within him and be the best at
that you know it's an early sign of
something that's come to Define their
relationship that Logan recognizes
there's something admirable about Wade
Wilson
while Wolverine and the X-Men first
battle Deadpool and the brother of evil
mutants in the Toys R Us promotional
comic X-Men Premium Edition issue 1
Logan officially takes on the Merc with
the mouth and Wolverine issue 88.
they're a union starts off with a bang
as Logan finds a mark with a mouth on
the prowl for his ex-girlfriend Vanessa
carcile and her new boyfriend Kane
unlike in the movies a comic book
Vanessa is a shape-shifting mercenary
called copycat not down with Wade's plan
Wolverine takes Deadpool on but gets
stabbed in the back with Wade's twin
swords Wolverine recovers and later
stops Deadpool from killing Kane and
copycat however Wade escapes by tossing
a grenade at Logan throughout the
adventure Wolverine fails to recognize
their ball as the same young man hit
Fort Worth against Hydra years earlier
this may be because Logan forgot Wade's
sense or it might be because Deadpool
nerdy 30 was published 27 years after
Wolverine issue 88. the X-Man and the
mouthy Merc cross paths again in
Wolverine annual 1995. this time
Wolverine's friend Maverick asked Logan
to help him save Wade Wilson from a
shadow organization that kidnapped
Deadpool to see if his healing Factor
can create a cure for the mutant killing
Legacy virus Logan initially refuses
seeing Deadpool as a stone killer but
comes around after Maverick points out
the scientists are torturing Wade just
like the Weapon X Program abused them
the two save Deadpool and Wade actually
helps Maverick leave the facility after
learning mavarek is in fact Dead with
the Legacy virus Logan and Maverick lose
track of Wade after the three leap down
of waterfall but Wolverine decides
Deadpool ain't a monster and that he'd
likely try helping to water cure in his
own way Logan's hunch proves right and
Deadpool sends blood and cell samples to
the X-Mansion for analysis while no
curious found it's the first time since
meeting Deadpool in costume that Logan
acknowledges Wade ain't all bad Logan
may have started seeing something
special about Deadpool but that doesn't
mean they get along right away in
Deadpool issue 27 Wade drives low Logan
into one of his famous Berserker rages
after he uses Ken sure you can move from
Street Fighter and sucker punches
Wolverine's friend Kitty Pride Logan
attacks but is brought back to Lucidity
by Wade's incessant bantering turns out
Wade only started this meaningless Super
Battle after his psychiatrist Dr bong
told him it would help him deal with his
recent hallucinations unfortunately
while shooting his hallucinations
Deadpool accidentally hits Logan's
acquaintance black crane making
Wolverine accuse Wade of having no honor
or remorse yet Logan also sympathizes
with Wilson noting he'd once been like
him thanks to Logan encouraging him to
deal with this pass as well as Dr bong
helping him understand what his Visions
represent Wade is able to make the
hallucinations disappear and recall his
wife Mercedes Wilson thus Logan plays a
key role in helping Deadpool's memory
and mental health even if their
encounter does end with Wolverine's
stabbing Dev ball with all of its claws
Logan's actually happy to find Wade
trying to kill Kitty Pride's favorite
horror author Duncan vess in Wolverine
annual 99 mostly because he can get back
at Deadpool for the sure you can
incident as if I say run into a werewolf
called like us who also has a beef with
vest turns out vess is secretly a
werewolf himself Wolverine ropes their
ball into keeping vest safe but Wade
ignores Logan's wishes luckily Logan
resurfaces before Deadpool can fulfill
his contract fending off both like us
and the people who hired Deadpool a
council of werewolves peeved a vest for
abandoning their kind and writing about
them in his books Deb paulden tries to
square things with Wolverine and after
punching Wade in the face Logan declares
or fuse between them are settled the
issue marks a turning point in the
character's relationship while Deadpool
claims he in Wolverine aren't friends
when he tries to kill VES Logan seems
keen on making amends by the story's end
even inviting a dazed Wade for a beer
after the face punch the catches at the
beers only for Logan and Wade's paying
despite their improving relationship
Logan becomes Deadpool's Target and
Wolverine issue 154 and 155 along with a
team of fellow mercenaries called The
Scourge Logan tries to get Wade to
reconsider but Deadpool fights Wolverine
anyway citing money worse and downs
Logan with a ton of potent tranquilizer
darts we later learned Deadpool's
employer and evil organization called
The Watchtower has offered to use
Logan's healing factor to treat the
injuries of Wade's friend Teresa Cassidy
and siren and restore her powers
surprisingly Wolverine doesn't hold us
against Wade deciding you can't change
what you are their fight ends when siren
rises from her tank fully healed finally
understanding Wade's true intentions
Wolverine lets Deadpool leave with siren
while he continues pursuing Watchtower
the whole ordeal is proof that Logan and
Waze Dynamic is changing rather than
looking to start a fight with Deadpool
Logan tries to talk him down Wade
meanwhile again gets agitated when
someone calls Logan his friend but only
out of guilt for kidnapping wolver
Marine Deadpool lights against recruited
into a new weapon x program after its
scientists temporarily fakes his scarred
face however he later turns on the
organization after fellow member
Sabertooth kills Wade's girlfriend
copycat Weapon X retaliates by turning
Wade's body to Mush leaving only a hand
which they send to Wolverine as a
warning Logan brings Wade's hand to the
merc's funeral in Deadpool issue 61
placing it in a casket with Deadpool's
costume the only two things left off him
fortunately Wade regenerates from the
hand at the end of the issue though he
probably would have preferred it if
Logan had kept the hands somewhere above
ground Wade returns a favor years later
in Death of Wolverine Deadpool and
Captain America issue one when he and
Steve Rogers destroyed Logan's remains
to evil parties can't clone him Wade
almost clones Wolverine himself for
benevolent purposes but decides to
imitate Logan instead in Wolverine's
Issue 13 to hilarious results seeing his
weights tenure as Wolverine ends with
him accidentally stabbing himself in the
head is probably probably for the best
that Logan later comes back to life and
resumes his duties between Deadpool
shooting Wolverine in the backing cable
and Deadpool issue 9 Logan slicing
Wade's head off over a misunderstanding
in cable and Deadpool issue 43 and a
tense rooftop showdown in Marvel team-up
issue 25 it's safe to say the two
characters Bon sour somewhat after
Wade's Resurrection this escalates in
Wolverine Origins issue 20-25 when Logan
again becomes a target of a contract
Wade's pursuing after enduring a lot of
hits stabs explosions and gunshot wounds
Wolverine is taken to Deadpool's
safehouse and chained above a pool in
which Wade intends to drown him Logan
stalls Deadpool however with enough
verbal Jabs to aggravate the normally
jovial Merc Wolverine reveals an even
bigger con he had the hit placed on
himself knowing Wade's attempts to kill
him with Lord Logan's son darken out
into the open you're so dark from the DC
Universe
The Showdown reveals that whatever
respect the two have for each other is
also accompanied by a lot of resentment
Deadpool Flats out states that killing
Wolverine is something he's envisioned
doing for some time while he due to his
frustration of being compared to him he
even expresses jealousy toward Logan
since despite their Mutual past as
killers the X-Men have no problem making
Wolverine a member yet refuse to let
Deadpool join Wade finally gets to try
out for the X-Men in Deadpool issue six
but watches his audition when he tries
to kill Alice Kincaid the father of
X-Men member Mercury it's Wolverine who
realizes it's all part of Wade's
elaborate plan to restore the X-Men's
reputation by having them save Kincaid
whose fals he accused them of holding
Mercury against her will while
Deadpool's plan succeeds his chaotic
nature costs him a place on the team
still Logan recruits Wade for his own
team X-Force friction forms however when
Deadpool objects to their teammate
phantomax killing a child version of
apocalypse and Logan nearly fires Wade
Wade later loses his healing factor in
Deadpool issue 53 leading to Logan whose
own healing gifts make him borderline
and killable asking Wade what it feels
like to be alive again despite their
many issues Wolverine keeps Deadpool on
the team and the two serve on X-Force
together until the team disbands after
mutant kind sets up its ownation on the
living Islands krakowa Deadpool recently
crowned Staten Island's monster King
gets displeased he's never been invited
and hitches a ride inside the gelatinous
body of the mutant gelby and Deadpool
issue 6. the X-Men learn about this and
agree to let Deadpool visit but only
through the proper channels before Wade
goes Rogue hands him a flower unique to
the island a gesture that she and
Wolverine explain is a token of the
X-Men's friendship it's a major moment
as not only does Logan finally say he
considers Deadpool the friend but
implies the X-Men feel the same you have
a good heart it belongs here where it
can grow
Deadpool later loses a Staten Island
royalty and decides he wants to live on
Cocoa after various foiled attempts to
break in again he tries convincing
Wolverine directly by botching a deal
Logan has been investigating between the
AI known as danger and the nefarious
ex-desk in Wolverine issue 20. the two
confront danger learning the X desk had
promised to return her cybernetic
daughter under the condition she create
an army of mechanized X-Men dupes for
them after Deadpool saves Wolverine from
danger Logan offers Deadpool the chance
to live on krakowa as part of the latest
incarnation of X-Force I just want to
say how proud I am of this team you know
you guys look amazing Wolverine and
Deadpool are far too popular to remain
confined to the comics page so it only
makes sense to run into each other in
animation in 2009's Hulk vs Wolverine
Logan is summoned by Department H to
stop the Hulk's Rampage but finds his
social with the Jade giant interrupted
when Deadpool shoots both of them with
tranquilizer darts Wolverine wakes up
chainsaw Warden Weapon X headquarters
where he learns he's being used as baits
so the program can capture and brainwash
the Hulk Wade shoots Wolverine in the
head but gets hit by the Ricochet
naturally Deadpool heals versus later
attempts to take down banner and Logan
don't go too well and Wolverine slices
his arm off after Banner transforms into
the Hulk Logan Chucks Wade's body at the
rampaging monster well Wade often talks
to Logan like he's an old buddy he makes
his feelings toward Wolverine quite
clear telling him we all hate you it's
fairly consistent with Deadpool's
portrayal in his earlier Comics the
humor slightly ramped up
Wolverine and Deadpool have it pretty
complicated in live action in X-Men
Origins Wolverine the two stars as
teammates working under William Striker
where Wade's constant white cracks annoy
Logan Wolverine later receives word that
Wade's been killed however Wade's
actually been transformed into Weapon XI
AKA weapon 11 armed with the power of
many mutants XI faces off against
Wolverine and Sabretooth leading to
Logan decapitating Wade and seemingly
killing him thanks to time travel
Shenanigans though Wade's time a
Striker's operative is wiped from
history when he reappears and the
Deadpool solo movies Wade doesn't know
of Logan however or at least a few
Jackman's Wolverine as he hilariously
wears a paper cut out of the actor's
face from a People magazine cover in
Deadpool 2 Wade gets ticked off by the
movie Logan which he feels has stolen
his Thunder by having an R rating and
killing off its star
well guess what will be
I'm dying in this one too Wades clearly
resolved his jealousy issues when the
two do encounter each other after
Deadpool travels back to the original
X-Men movie timeline and helps out Logan
by shooting his Weapon XI self in the
head and their rivalry seems to have
called in the real world as well after
years of engaging in a friendly Feud
Jackman finally agreed to a request made
by Deadpool actor Ryan Reynolds hey Hugh
you want to play Wolverine one more time
yeah sure right the announcement which
also sees both Deadpool and Wolverine
joining the MCU promises to take Logan
and the Merc with a mouth to exciting
new places as we watch their complex
relationship continue to evolve
foreign
[Music]